i want to talk about
an inflamed liver
the problem with people that have
inflammation in the liver is many times
they don't know they have inflammation
in the liver and it progresses
uh developing scar tissue and then
fibrosis and then cirrhosis and so the
good news about the liver
is that it's robust and it is one of the
only organs that can completely
regenerate but you also have to realize
that there are so many people out there
that have inflammation in the liver and
they don't have a clue and it's building
up over time and a lot of symptoms don't
occur until later in life but one of the
big symptoms is that you're just a
little lethargic a little tired and you
don't know that's connected to inflamed
liver
i had an inflamed liver for many years
and i didn't really know it in fact i
had a lot of the symptoms in my right
shoulder right up to my neck and i had
no idea that was my liver and if someone
would have educated me on that a long
time ago
i would have been able to do something
about it and now my weakness is my liver
and so if you have inflammation in your
liver or scar tissue or even a fatty
liver
that can also give you a lot of
additional problems like arthritis and
thyroid function
and a lot of digestive issues and
weakness within the gallbladder because
the liver makes bile and if you don't
have the full liver capacity
you're not going to have the bile to
help you digest all the fat soluble
vitamins and so the first thing you need
to know is what are the most common
things that can cause
inflammation in your liver number one
sugar number two refined carbohydrates
number three alcohol number four
vegetable oils which is in most of your
foods if you go to the grocery store soy
oil corn oil canola
cotton seed
very very damaging on the liver
also too much snacking can raise insulin
and create a lot of inflammation in your
liver as well and also there are people
that have a lot of autoimmune diseases
okay
so their own immune system is attacking
their own organs and
in autoimmune conditions people nearly
always have an inflamed liver and so if
you're watching and you have an
autoimmune disease
this video is for you
the the problem with inflammation in
general is that cancer tends to travel
to areas of inflammation so your goal
should be to eliminate as much
inflammation
as possible just to prevent any cancer
from traveling if you happen to get
cancer
with inflammation of liver over time you
slowly lose liver function but it's very
very
slow and you might not even be aware
that it's occurring until it's pretty
well invaded
uh most of the liver function the
interesting thing about the liver is you
don't need much of it to function
normally it's a robust organ it can take
a beating and it can completely
regenerate if you don't let it get too
far cruciferous vegetables are probably
one of the best things you can consume
to help support the liver alright let's
talk about the things that you should be
doing if you have an inflamed liver
milk thistle very important 500
milligrams per day okay milk thistle
it's called hepatoprotective it protects
the liver cells
next thing is vitamin d vitamin d is the
best natural anti-inflammatory
it has virtually no side effects and i
would take vitamin d at levels between
10 000 to 20 000 or even more
per day those are iu's international
units and more if you have a lot of
information or an autoimmune disease the
next thing i would highly recommend and
this is very very important is fasting
at least 18 hours of no food you can
drink water but no food in that 18 hours
okay so you'd have six hour eating
window and 18 hours of fasting that's
going to give you a tremendous amount of
what's called autophagy which is going
to help to
repair liver function it's going to help
to
take these damaged proteins in the liver
the scar tissue and help to recycle that
into new liver tissue
very very very important
the other
remedy i'm going to recommend is called
tutco tutka is my secret remedy to a lot
of different conditions
especially with inflammation in your
liver
basically tutka is bare bile okay
it's made synthetically but even though
it's synthetic it seems to be something
that's uh very beneficial and i've never
seen any negative effects from taking
tutta i would take two in the morning on
an empty stomach and two in the
afternoon on an empty stomach and it's
going to increase the flow of bile it's
going to create a nice anti-inflammatory
effect
very cool stuff
and then tocatrinals this is a type of
vitamin e
one of the best most powerful types of
vitamin e like 50 times stronger than
tocopherols take 300 milligrams
per day
with a meal and the tocotrienols the
vitamin e is going to go in there and
really clean up the free radicals for
you very powerful as an
anti-inflammatory very good also for
any type of heart problems and coronary
artery problems
and then the last thing is selenium at
200 micrograms not milligrams micrograms
selenium is a very good antioxidant for
the liver it's also good to help
decrease the risk for cancer it's also
good for the thyroid in converting t4 to
t3 but overall we have milk thistle
vitamin d fasting tut cut tocatrino
selenium and cruciferous vegetables are
all important for an inflamed liver and
also preventing
the scarring of the liver
hey before you go
if you're benefiting from any of my
content i would love to hear about your
success story
please share it in the link down below